You only recommend one product for both my mycotoxins and my other toxins, why only one thing?
Because usually I've already put you on things to help with your liver.
And I'm hoping that you do the other things that I just spoke about in that last question,
about dealing with stimulating your parasympathetics and calming your sympathetic.
And many times, you know, the products that are out there are not going to be...
There's no products that are going to be specific to X toxin.
I have benzene toxicity, so what's the anti-benzene product that I'm going to take?
Well, there isn't an anti-benzene product.
There's something that's going to keylate the benzene out of your system.
There's also going to keylate mycotoxins and keylate other toxins and keylate heavy metals.
So, they're not even though they might have fancy names on the product like mycopole.
You know, what's a mycopole for?
It's to pull mycotoxins out of your body.
Well, yeah, but it's really ingredients.
That will help pull heavy metals, that will help pull poisons and benzene and other toxins on the toxicity test.
Nutritional companies have to give it a name in order to appeal to a people group that are looking for such product.
But in truth, it's not going to be only specific to one thing.
Secondly, I don't want to put people on ten different things that you're going to have supplement burdo with just supporting detox pathways.
Thirdly, we don't want to detox so fast.
If you're going to use a key later, you're pulling stuff out of the tissue.
It's still less to go through the liver.
So, go back to the seven phases of detoxification information that you have available to you with the seven phases of detoxification course.
You have to be doing everything to be supporting phase six, which is dumping into the toilet, making sure that you're having adequate daily bowel movements.
Phase five, that you're binding things.
That's why what I typically recommend something, it's going to be a binder plus a key later.
So you're binding things in the large intestines and that you're not reabsorbing the stuff that your liver is putting trying to get rid of.
And then phase four is that you're making adequate bile.
That really has to do with the parasympathetic nervous system.
And that's where, excuse me, coffee in them is in hot packs over the liver can help decrease the viscosity of your bile to get bile flow so that you're able to get rid of these things.
Remember, all your toxins from phase one and phase two of the liver are then bound with phase three, the production of bile.
Which then is all of those toxins go through bile via encased in bile into the gall bladder and then into the duodenum.
And then you have to get it into the toilet.
So phase one, two, three, four, five, six is so essential in order for you to get rid of things.
And if you're going to put too much stress on phase zero, which is key lady to doubt of the tissue, it's going to your grabbing too much out of the tissue too fast.
It's going into the liver and the liver is like, hey, settle down here, you know, you're in dumped home on shit here. I can't take anymore.
And all you're going to be doing is transporting this through the blood and dumping it into some other tissue area, which so you have to key late slowly.
And you have to be making sure you're supporting phase one through six before you hold too much out on phase zero and too much for your liver to handle.